Let's go ahead and take a look at fog and how we can optimize the scene in such ways that we can get the best performance out of it for ICV effects.
Now there are a few things you need to consider when working with ICV effects when it comes to fog.
There are three primary things that do affect your fog and overall and how things are going to look.
Now we can turn general fog on, if we go to our actual fog, we're using an exponential height fog.
This gives us the option to be able to work with volumetrics.
And volumetrics will allow us to have a bit more realism in our scene.
This is key to be able to control how things are going to look and there are several settings in here that allow you to adjust them to dumb down your fog and to dumb down or push back the fog in any particular way, which might be needed on ICV effects stage.
There's also the condition or I should say setting that can influence your fog and that is within the light itself.
If we scroll down, we'll see volumetric scatter intensity.
If I increase this, you'll see the light and fog appear to magnify together.
It's basically making it so that the light becomes a bit more stronger and influencing how your fog is digesting that relationship.
Like in the real world, the more fog that you have, or the brighter your light, the brighter your scene will be overall.
So you're actually using a nice secondary type of setting here, volumetric scatter intensity, and increasing it without actually dealing with the brightness of the light or the increase of the fog itself.
So it gives you a little extra tuning if you need.
So in the light, if I increase my light strength, you'll actually get a brighter scene, but you'll see your fog areas magnify.
And we're using lumen in this particular case.
So in here also what can occur if I go to my fog itself, I can increase my fog density and that too will also bring up the magnification of brightness in the scene.
So you can see again that our fog works like in the real world.
And volumetric is a big part of that.
The nice thing about volumetric fog, if I increase our overall fog density and even tweak my fall off so that it's pushed even farther forward,
you'll notice that it's invading most of my scene except my interior, which is kind of what we want.
Older versions of our fog would actually be limited and would actually invade interior areas.
So we would have to find a cutoff point or push back the fall off so they wouldn't invade this particular areas and maybe even use fog cards to fake a few things.
We hit control Z here to put us back the way we were.
And you can see being able to have that volumetrics digested and actually work the way it works in the real world is actually really helpful.
Makes it so that my interior scene does not get invaded with fog or any ground cover such as trees and so forth will not be invaded with fog also.
So the volumetrics will kind of honor that and be clipped off and cut off from those particular areas, which is kind of what you want.
Nobody wants the fog to invade everywhere.
So in this particular case, those are some of the things you have to consider when controlling your fog.
But let's actually get to exponential height fog for just one moment here and let's actually look at a few things that we can do to control our scene.
So we talked about initially you can control your fog density in your height in your fog fall off.
But there's also the fog in scattered color.
This is primary to decide whether you want your fog to be influenced by its environment global illumination that is occurring or you want to be able to control that color primary.
It's set to black right now.
It being set to black makes it that I'm plucking or getting most of my color information, the bounces and so forth from my actual environment.
But if I go in here and change that color, you'll now see that we can actually control and also based on strength,
we can control the color of our fog and even customize things as we need, which is actually super helpful.
I'm going to cancel there and we're going to undo that.
I'm going to undo the density here and get it back to our original setting.
We have in the scatter we talked about in scatter color and there's also sky atmosphere ambient contribution color scale.
So this can be changed to you can change that and you definitely see a change in our fog.
So you have a lot of customization options and we at Epic Games want to make sure that you feel drunk with power.
They can do anything.
So you have a lot of settings to be able to control what you need.
There's a fog max opacity to so we can actually completely remove the fog.
So it's a very clear day where we can go in and get it a little bit more believable for a beach scene and a little bit of fog in the distance.
You can control that distance and fog cut off distance.
Also, you also have in scattering textures.
So if we wanted to put in a color cube map, we could one of our choosing for our environment.
You can see I just loaded a default little generic one and you already see the changes and the brightness based on that.
And it tries to imitate the bounce using that cube map as a reference.
I'm going to undo that.
So you have a lot of options here which allow us to be able to control and get the look and feel that we need.
There's even directional in scattering that you can control.
Volumetrics are very handy.
You see that we have a scatter contribution overall and we can control this too.
And you can see as we change it, the fog will change in how things are being distributed in our scene.
There's an albedo and an emissive we can also control.
So if we wanted to get our fog a little bit more on a London type of look, a London scale, we can actually increase that.
But you'll notice our interior seems to get a bit more invaded with that in this particular case.
So you do need to be careful with that if you decide to use those because the emissive is an overall glow.
That doesn't mean that everything's going to be excluded.
In a natural area where you don't have emissive everywhere, it won't poke through these interior environments.
But if you turn it on, the glow doesn't quite obey those particular rules.
There's also static lighting scattering intensity.
We don't really have any static lighting in our particular scene.
So if we mess with this, you'll see that a lot of that seems to go anywhere.
But it can give you, in some cases, some cheap ground fog or extra layers of fog to be helpful.
And there are some CVARs we definitely want to look at when working with Unreal.
Let's go ahead and take a look at some primary settings real quick in our slides,
so you can get a better understanding of how some of this is unfolded.
So we talked about a few things, one of them being the indirect lighting intensity.
We can control our cast volumetric shadows.
You can also turn these on too, but they are expensive.
They will give you a bit more realism, but not necessarily will make things better overall.
It just depends on it's a case by case scenario, what you're trying to do and the look you're going for.
So you may not even need this, but the option's there.
We talked about volumetric scatter intensity here, which allows you to go in here
and you can control how strong that light's coming through with your overall scene.
So the indirect lighting intensity, which we mentioned here,
we can go in here and this scales up our overall light and GI contribution.
So if I go here, you can see there's definite brightness and a little bit more haziness
because again, Unreal is taking in count the fog that we have in place.
But your overall intensity also will also be magnified with the fog
and control that influence too.
So there's a lot of logic in here, like in the real world where those things are controlled.
Let's go ahead and take a look at some CVars that we can use
and we're going to use a thing called our console variable.
So if I go to my console variable here and I pop this up,
we're going to load a few and I'm going to show you some of the ones
and the settings you should shoot for when working with fog in your environment.
So let's go ahead and load some console variables in here.
One of the first ones I'll look at here is our volumetric grid size here, pixel size.
So we'll go ahead and hit console variable.
And I'm just going to save a bit of time of typing in and just paste it in.
Volumetric grid pixel size.
And you'll see that it loads and it shows me exactly where my console settings are set at
for that particular one.
Another one we'll take a look at is our volumetric fog grid size Z
and we'll do that in just a second.
But let's talk about this one a little bit because it can be a little bit confusing
where the settings kind of hit.
The default on this is eight.
It can be lowered to six.
I have mine set to four.
Anything higher than eight though can increase performance
but at the cost of pixelation.
So if I go higher in this particular case, it's going to cause pixelation.
So mine's at four.
It gives me a pretty decent amount of fog and it isn't too bad on our volume.
So you have to adjust these settings accordingly.
Just keep in mind the higher you go,
you actually can get better performance but at the cost of visuals.
Another one, which I just mentioned a second ago,
is our volumetric fog grid size Z.
Again, all we are doing is stretching and moving things around.
You can think of it as over a canvas
and I'm changing these settings to accommodate visuals.
So this particular one is set at a default to 128.
The lower values increase performance but may cause pixelation also.
Higher will get better visuals but at a performance cost.
So when I actually can raise this up if I needed to,
the nice thing about this is you can test these out on the fly.
We can even have it go in here
and let's actually change our volumetrics to be on and off.
So you can actually test your performance.
So I will go to my console variable, just overall fog in here
and just hit enter on this one.
And we can turn this on and off
and you can use your GPU profile soft, GPU profile tools
to be able to see if it's going to give you what you need
and you're like, I need to turn this off
and I need to change my grid size.
And if you wanted to, you can even have it so your overall intensity,
you can punch in those numbers.
There's no particular slider option in here,
which actually would be kind of nice but we don't have it at this time.
So you could do a happy compromise
where your grid fog pixel size can be set to
and these are actually not bad.
This is not a bad approach for these settings.
We could set our volumetric fog grid pixel size to six
and then we can change our volumetric fog grid size Z to 96
if you're running to some performance.
You have to test these out.
This is a case by case scenario.
And then we can also turn it on and off
to see if or how much of an impact that fog is having on our scene.
So those are just some things to keep in mind.
Let's go ahead and take a look at another scene that I have set up.
We're going to take a look at fog cards and fog materials,
which can help complement a scene,
but everything has to be done with a grain of salt.
So you have to make sure when you do use these,
they are material heavy,
that the compromise isn't going to be sacrificing your scene quality
versus your frame rate.
You have to figure out what's a good balance.
And we're going to look at those two options.
So here's another scene that I have some fog different tools
to be able to actually get the fog working the way that we like
and to be able to even exaggerate the fog on a somewhat cheaper level.
Now materials are still expensive.
I have several fog cards and volumetric materials in here.
And if I go and go to my LIT
and I take a look at my optimization view modes,
you'll see shader complexity is pretty high on the darker red area.
Now they're not hitting the white zone, which is fine, which is good.
And they're not hitting pink.
So you could still use these in a volumetric scenario and do pretty well.
But everything again with a grain of salt,
because you have to keep in mind everything that's populating your scene.
If you're using this with fog,
again, you have to figure out where your give and take will be.
And if you can use less fog and use more of these,
or if you need more fog and just these to be icing on the cake,
it's really up to you.
So let's go back to LIT mode.
You can see I even have moving fog in here.
This is being done through material and in a fog card
and actually works pretty well.
But you'll notice there's a bit of flickering going on.
We'll unpack that in just a bit,
because you do need to be careful with this when building the shader.
Now, we're not going to build a whole shader,
but I'm going to give you the scene
and I'm going to walk you through what I have in here
so you can understand some of the capabilities that you have.
And then we're going to also talk about that second layer of fog data
that you can build right within the fog environment.
So in here right now, there are several different things in place.
I have a moving fog card in here.
Let's go and take a look at him up close.
This moving fog card has a depth opacity, a fade distance,
a speed X and a speed Y.
Let's look at how we set that up.
So in my material, it's actually pretty simple.
I have a panner set in with a texture sample.
Now, this can be anything of your choosing,
but I made sure that that repeating pattern is actually repeating.
I've repeated myself about the repeating pattern,
but the repeat, we want to be able to do that
because then you make sure that you're not hitting any seams
as you're testing things out, changing your XYZ speed
or even your UVs if you decided to go in here
and edit your coordinates.
You want to be able to have something that's repetitive,
that you don't run into any issues and seams that could pop up.
So I have a panner in here.
I put it in a pen so I can control the speed of the X
and the speed of Y.
It actually works out really well.
So I also have the, over here, a depth opacity,
which is in a depth fade.
I made sure I loaded that and a fade distance.
Each scaler is to be able to control those variables.
Up above, you'll see we have a radial gradient exponential,
and this is actually working well.
It's coming into my depth fade with a multiply,
and my multiply over here is grabbing the texture
and movement information,
and that multiply finally is going to opacity,
and I'm using that radial gradient
and putting it into my base color.
One thing I want to point out, though, in here,
if I type in DOF,
you'll notice that I have before depth of field,
and that's because my material overall
is a translucent object.
So you want to make sure, it being translucent,
that you don't run into any sorting issues,
and you may want to turn this on.
This really just depends on where things are placed
in your scene, but this can be very helpful.
That's pretty much it for that particular material,
and it actually works out pretty well.
Get a nice little creepy fog rolling across here.
It's not a high-resolution texture,
and it almost gives you an optical illusion
if we go up, that's just a card,
but when you look on it straight,
it almost looks like there's fog in the distance
versus somewhere else.
And you can easily go in here and magnify this
by simply going in, go ahead and do another.
I'm hitting Alt, and I'm moving this back here
on the X-axis, and now you have several layers of fog,
and if I wanted to, I could make another material
and slow that one down.
So they're not kind of moving in unison.
So you get little different layers of movement.
I'm not going to bother doing that,
so that's pretty straightforward,
but you can see how you can change that.
The other material that I have in here,
and we'll look at another fog card,
is I'm going to pull back a bit,
and you'll see that I have another one in here
of a different color.
This one actually works pretty well.
This is used in one of our other scenes,
but I'm making it accessible for you to play with.
And let's go and grab them on the other side
so it wants to grab the cube.
There you go.
So I have several different fog cards in here.
Not just one, but two, and you can see them
as I move my camera around.
So these fog cards, excuse me, work really great.
I can go in here with this particular fog card,
and let's go and take a look at its blueprint.
So it's trapped in a blueprint.
We're going to go to our viewport.
I'm going to click on that fog card,
and his resolution is pretty cheap,
but he's a bit more complex in his setup.
So let's go to the parent material.
In the parent material, if I click on the grid here,
you'll see that it's a surface, an additive.
So you want to make sure that in these particular fog cards,
when you're making them,
you're going to be using a translucent object.
And you want to make sure,
let's go back into that other one I had.
You'll notice this one's translucent,
so he's a bit different with his blend mode.
But this other one I'm showing you is additive.
Just want to point that out
because it could be maybe a little bit confusing
for some people.
But you kind of get the same result.
This just depends how you lay it out.
Let's go back into that edit of the blueprint.
Go to the viewport.
Let's go back to that material.
We'll go to the parent material.
And you'll see this one is laid out
a little bit more complex.
There's a texture coordinate.
There's the panning speed with a multiply and a time.
And each one is going into a pattern.
And it's nice that we make it
look like it's three-dimensional.
We have a tiling mask A and a tiling mask B.
Each one going into a multiply,
into a multiply here,
and up above we have color we're pulling through.
You'll notice we have a camera vector we're playing with
and a pixel normal WS.
And this allows us to mess with a transform vector here.
And you'll see down below,
oh, you'll notice we have an ABS.
And now anytime you're not sure about these,
feel free to do control-alt.
It gives you a breakdown.
This is an abbreviation
for the mathematical term absolute value.
So this gets our absolute value from this particular item
taken in from that dot product,
and allows us to be able to get
some really nice camera vector movement and positioning.
You'll notice down here it gets a little bit confusing,
but it's really just several masks
going in here with a minus and a lerp.
Now, if you do run into problems,
feel free to reorganize these any way that you want.
It can be a noodle fest if you're not careful.
But I gave this to you
so you can actually play with it.
This comes from one of our scenes.
And it's a pretty simple, believe it or not,
not complicated texture.
If I go to my texture sample here,
you'll see it's sand and dust storm mask.
And again, we're using that depth fade in here
with a soft edge all around scale
that we're using within our alpha control in our lerp.
Pretty nice.
And you'll notice, though, this is key
and kind of unusual for some people.
You'll see that there's a customized UV.
Yes, there is customized UVs that you can put in here.
And if you want it needed to shift the UVs just a bit,
you can.
And you can just type in custom.
Let me make sure I hit grid here.
You can see a number of customized UVs.
And you can put that in here
and you can shift things a bit if you need it.
That's kind of a rundown with that particular material.
Let's go ahead and take a look at the volumetric material.
And then we're going to unpack our fog in general
and talk about some of the fog layers
that you can create with your exponential height fog.
So I'm clicking on this particular material,
and we're not going to build the whole thing,
but I'm just going to walk you through it.
This particular material actually works pretty well.
And again, these materials can be complex.
But for some quick layers of fog and control,
they can be priceless.
You'll notice I have a distance amount, a fog magnifier.
You'll see I also have a mass size, a mass size divide.
If we go to the parent, you'll see them unpacked.
And I have some notes in here too
that help out a little bit.
You'll see we have an absolute world position.
And in here I have a mask size and mass size divide.
Now what that does, if I want to adjust the look and feel
between these coming in here, I can.
So you'll see we have a mask input and a multiply.
We have a panner and in here I added in the pen.
Now we could go straight to a speed, overall speed,
but I wanted to be able to control my U speed
and my V speed and be able to separate those
and not just have one speed control.
So if I wanted to raise higher or go more vertical,
I could do that.
There's a mask for effect going into the texture
and I'm using a thing called the three point levels.
You'll see probably several tutorials online
that talk about how to use this
and they use it quite often.
There's a mask edits.
Mask edits, it's really just my four constant vector
and I renamed them to go into my black value,
middle value and white value.
So you can mess with this color
and relate to that to your object.
You'll notice there's a static fog control
that I created here too.
Absolute world position, transform position
and local object bounds.
Now there are multiple ways again to do this and tackle it.
But this gives you an idea of what you can do
and you'll see our multiply comes to the very end here
using an opacity to control extinction
and we have the overall color.
Now our color is also being influenced by our fog.
If we go back to that material just for a second,
you'll notice when I click on here,
it is a volume material.
So that volume material does require that fog be enabled.
If you don't have fog enabled,
this volume material is not gonna show up.
So it's very complimentary.
The fog cards are a bit different
and what I mean by that if I type in fog
and I turn off my exponential height fog,
you'll notice that goes away
but my fog cards are still present.
So they're not dependent on it
but that particular material is.
Just keep those things in mind.
So let's talk briefly about our fog layers.
So if we go into our fog layers,
you'll notice it's a lot foggier down there than up here.
This is kind of status quo
but down here it's a bit thicker.
This is what I meant by an exponential height fog.
You have a thing called secondary fog data.
This is really great.
You can control some extra fog data.
Notice my scene really isn't being impacted
because my height is down below versus up above.
This can make it so that you have a scene
where actors are up above looking down at a cliffside
or an environment down below and one might have more fog.
There's a lot of fun can be had here.
You can control the fog height fall off
and fog height offset.
Also within your directional light,
if you wanted to and your camera's facing the sun,
you can use a thing called our god rays
and you'll see that it's underneath light shafts.
I have turned on light shaft occlusion
in this particular case
and we can see the difference between them.
If I turn it off,
we're straight using fog information
and this is actually pretty realistic
in the fact that if I turn my camera,
those beams and shafts of fog light still stay present.
The only downside of using this light shafts
is it's based on your camera direction.
So as soon as I turn my camera,
those things will fade away and clip away.
So it's not quite realistic.
It's more of a screen space type of effect.
There's even a light shaft bloom
if you wanted to add more of that
and you'll notice when I turn my camera,
that really shows up,
that screen space type of effect
where it kind of clips away.
So if your camera's facing, it's great.
If it's not, they may not be exactly what you want.
Let's keep those things in mind.
All right, well that's about it
with a rundown for fog when it comes to ICV effects.
I hope that helped you out
and you enjoyed this section of the course.